[Music]
challenges that we face were not alone
in them the things that we're thinking
about doing were not alone in them
either and that someone has been there
before or going to try after and that's
the greatest value to sort of seek a
group support
[Music]
Mike had mentioned earlier as well about
how you there is a need for some kind of
tangibility and measurement so that we
can go back to people who don't care
about designs I think you need you need
to be able to make comparisons
internationally and I think there are
perhaps a few macro indicators that I
think we do we should be collecting
within the framework there are still
complex to collect but which are I think
useful for informing policy
[Music]
design economy is closer to social
issues now and bringing impact also not
on only to the companies and their
selling side but also to this whole
society and our environment and I think
this is something which really and adds
value to our work
[Music]
and I think you are doing a good job I
think there would be far worse off
without the design organizations that
and one things we didn't really talk
about is what what you do for the design
industry we keep measuring the
effectiveness of what we do what design
does for industry or than clients and
companies and SMEs but actually the
organization's have a very very
beneficial effect on the design industry
in the creative industries
[Music]